airbags deployed let's shut this
intersection
down a wild crash caught on dash camera
video as a suspect drives his car
directly under a box truck and it all
started when he sped off from police
leading them on a high-speed chase
Center Line's blocking uh it's up in the
grass just just just just parallel just
parallel just
parallel
it begins with a traffic stop in Warren
Michigan on December 26th dash camera
video shows officers pull over the
vehicle for expired
plates the window broke can you put the
car in part
please uh so the reason I stopped you is
cuz the plates expired car yeah I'm just
coming from work oh yeah um is this your
car no it's my girlfriend down street
did you have your license with you and
registration insurance I don't have my
life nothing when the driver says he
doesn't have any ID officers ask him to
step outside he chooses to ignore their
directions and instead just drives off
oh what I got to have you do is just hop
out for me real quick man cuz you don't
have your license out there okay no no
no no
no
immediately the chase is on as video
captures the suspect speed through a
neighborhood and even drive their car
through the grass nor heing the grass
jumping back down
[Music]
nor uh dreads dreads 20 short dreads
10 10 to
10 black
threads
[Music]
tattoo who out there but the driver's
time on the road was shortlived as he
hops the curb again in an effort to
avoid the now multiple squads on his
tail Center Line's blocking uh he up in
the
grass just just just just parallel just
parallel just
parallel
all right we got the lead again from
Center Line he's jumping through the
grass uh just south of 10 and East on
Lawrence somebody go to Sherwood in 10 m
for
me all right we're uh by that apartment
complex uh just east of Sherwood coming
out to
10 all right West on West on 10 west on
10 you're good clear sorry y yep y
approaching
shwood shwood
shwood on
[Music]
BL give him some
roll
[Music]
traffic
as the chase continues officers note the
suspect is approaching a red light for
Ryan a red he speeds through the light
and drives straight under a Pensky
[Music]
van 50 into a box truck he's underneath
the box
truck airbags deployed let's shut this
intersection
down the driver was pronounced dead on
the scene
another crazy crash caught on dash cam
this time out of Georgia and it happened
when the suspect sped off from Cops
after trying to make a stop at the
McDonald's drive-thru he ran from police
with three kids in the
[Music]
car this happened in Atlanta on December
20th officers responded to a shots fired
call after a suspect in a gray SUV shot
toward a building narrowly missing
people nearby the suspect was later
identified as William buris when police
got eyes on bis's vehicle they followed
him into a McDonald's parking lot he
even pulled up into the drive-thru but
wasn't able to get his Happy Meal when
officers tried to pull him over he sped
off
[Music]
you can see in the video the passenger
side door keeps opening as burus drives
around McDonald's soon we see why when
he comes to a stop and someone jumps out
of the front seat burus then proves
nothing good starts in a getaway car and
makes a break for it leading police on a
[Music]
chase video captures him run multiple
stop signs and a red
[Music]
light
Avenue Avenue very rightly very
rightly finally as police inch closer
they bump the back of bur's SUV the the
car can be seen flying out of
frame it's only after circling back to
this crash that officers realized there
had been three kids inside the vehicle
all
along oh my
God
[Music]
mmyy out of
way come here sweeti come here sweeti
come here come here
okay you're okay you're okay you're okay
you're all right you'll be all right
you'll be all right you okay
s when the kids are out safe officers
take burus into custody come on let's go
listen I got you hey man listen just
bring bring hold let's
this I got you I got
you somebody go back lethal I got you I
got you come
on come on one two
three out come
on officials later learn burus was a
convicted felon who they say had 37
previous arrest Cycles they also found a
gun in the vehicle burus now faces
multiple charges including fleeing and
alluding cruelty to kids and aggravating
assault with a deadly weapon all right
we're going to get back to this body cam
in a second but I want to take a minute
to talk about something else that
happens all the time workplace injuries
if you get hurt at your job whether it's
a slip and fall a mechanical failure
negligence of your co-workers something
hits you you're going to need a trusted
law firm in your corner enter Pon Le
hockey Giordano a firm that is a
heavyweight in the industry that wins
all different kinds of injury cases yes
workplace but also accidents Social
Security dis ability injuries they have
a track record of recovering over $1
billion for their clients and they have
won over a 100,000 cases they have 250
years of combined experience how amazing
is that so you can check out Pon Le
hockey Giordano at ponle hockey.com
LC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body
cam
switching from high-speed chases to a
foot chase where police in Dayton Ohio
track down a wanted suspect where's it
at ear it sounds weird no it's all right
but back in the suspect is a real
chicken nicknamed Virginia by police
officers say they've received calls
about the animal chasing people they
arrived on the scene to apprehend the
suspect he keep coming out sh and I
think he's been back here in my I swear
that's not my about 30 seconds into the
body cam video the responding officer
first gets eyes on the suspect you see
him is there a rooster oh there he is oh
yeah that's a rooster when the officer
approaches at a walk the suspect runs
off come on
but after that narrow escape the officer
zeros in on the chicken again and this
time the chicken is backed into a
corner but just like that the chicken is
on the run again besting the officer for
a second
time come
here the officer doesn't give up though
he continues the chase at a
run but soon slows to a walk lulling the
suspect into a false sense of
security the suspect picks it back up
into a run and just when the officer
thinks he's finally caught
it the chicken breaks free once
again for a few seconds the chase is
back up to a
run and just when we think the chase
will never end the officer gets his
hands on The Wanted
suspect
as is customary after an arrest the
suspect is put in the back seat of the
officer's squad
car thank you reporting for long crime
I'm Sierra Gillespie